from the very
beginning when we first started talking
about doing this black widow standalone
film
there was no reason to
do it unless we could really dig
deep black widow had an enormous amount
of her past
that has never been explored before and
what's fun about doing that
now is we get to see scarlett as this
amazing amazing
actor and performer with an entirely new
cast of characters in this film
i've of course over the years thought
about what it could be
but it never would have been able to be
as fully realized as it is now because
i've spent over a decade of time with
this character
i would love to take this character in
every different direction i think
she certainly encounters her fair share
of the marvel universe
the part that appealed to me most about
her is her dedication than just her
intelligence she really helped design
the costume helped to flesh out
the character to be a part of this is
pretty exciting i didn't know
how the fans would respond i think that
there is so much to explore with black
widow her past
is something that's always been shrouded
in mystery you know it's kind of hard to
trust someone when you don't know who
that someone really is
yeah really the most important aspect of
my job is to keep a sort of steady
evolution she has a greater calling
the last five years i've been trying to
do one thing get to write here
that's all it's been about bringing
everybody back this character who
has searched her whole life for a
purpose actually
finds her purpose it's okay
it is the single most heroic moment
in the history of the marvel universe
you know the hope was always to be able
to do much more with black widow and
with each appearance with each
interaction growing and involving her
all frankly building
to her standalone movie now
we had the opportunity in this for some
sort of healing
and i think you really feel that the way
scarlet portrays this hero in this movie
is bigger
and better than anything you've seen her
do in any of the marvel movies
it's gonna let people see
who natasha really is
i've lived a lot of lives
you